in the latest news from the sort of hear no
evil, see no evil camp.
Donald Trump has fired the internal pollsters
that I told you about last week who did polls
for Trump and really important battleground
states and came back to him and said, hey,
you're down in these states in hypothetical
match ups against Biden, Bernie Warren, you're
losing, you're losing in these states.
And the numbers were not super surprising
because Trump's own internal polls found he
was down to Biden and Michigan and Wisconsin
and his favor ability has been negative in
Michigan and Wisconsin for a while.
In other words, the numbers Trump got from
his pollsters were completely and totally
consistent with what the public information
has been for several months, which was that
Trump is not doing well in these states.
And if the election were held today, he would
likely lose.
Trump had internal polls from 17 different
states and the numbers were very concerning
and many of them and what Donald Trump has
done, instead of saying, wow, I really need
to get a campaign together, he has instead
fired the pollsters effectively saying, kill
the Messenger.
But, uh, Baze lease and associates have been
fired.
Adam Geller, uh, who has been upholster for
Trump since 2016 has been fired.
The polling company run by Brett Lloyd has
been fired.
And fascinatingly, it's being reported that
Donald Trump fired them.
Not only or specifically because Trump necessarily
thinks the polls are wrong, but because Trump
is also furious about the fact that the polls
leaked, which is so funny because every public
poll said the exact same thing.
In other words, even without the internal
polls leaking, every poll that is being done
right now shows that Donald Trump is down
in those key battleground states.
So I don't believe for a second that being
down isn't a factor.
Trump obviously doesn't like polls that say
that he's down.
Uh, but even if he thinks the numbers are
false, he seems genuinely angry with the pollsters
that the information became public, which
is just so silly because it's all public anyway.
So the reaction we want to, this is the same
as what I said last week.
We want Donald Trump to think he's winning.
Okay?
If Donald Trump thinks he's winning, he'll
campaign less.
He'll take more for granted, and it will just
make it more likely that Donald Trump will
actually end up losing in 2020.
And part of this is Donald Trump's fragile
ego, which we've become very well acquainted
with over the last couple of years.
Part of this is Trump's narcissism, as bill
eddy pointed out and told us about on yesterday's
program, a licensed mental health professional.
But the most important thing in the end is
that Democrats benefit from a Trump that believes
that he's ahead.
We want Trump to campaign less, which he will
do if he thinks he's winning.
So even though it's hilarious that Donald
Trump is so triggered by negative poles that
he's firing pollsters and saying suppressed
the information, the less Trump campaigns,
the better off the eventual democratic nominee
will be.
Now imagine working at the White House.
Now Trump wants just good news.
So if you work at the White House, it, whether
you're a pollster, a staffer and aid, whatever,
you are in the position where you either have
to lie to Trump and give him only good fake
news all the time, or you tell the truth and
you risk losing your job and getting fired
as many people already have.
It's sort of like working for one of those
authoritarian dictators that have to be placated
at all times, which is yet another similarity
between Donald Trump and that group, which
is a group not typically similar to or associated
with the American president.
But of course that has changed significantly
under Donald Trump.
And there's this really strange circle when
it comes to the polling, because the regular
sort of Magda EITs, Trump is talking point
is we can't trust the polls because in 2016
the poll said Hillary would win and Hillary
lost.
Of course, the truth is that the national
polls in 2016 said Hillary would win the popular
vote by two to three points, and Hillary won
the popular vote by two to three points, but
it doesn't matter.
The Manga EIT talking point is the polls are
fake.
So now the polls say Trump is losing, and
they see that as confirmation that the polls
are biased because they were supposedly wrong
in 2016 even though they weren't, and they
don't even consider the possibility that Donald
Trump could actually be losing.
So the result is that the pollsters actually
are the ones that get fired.
Here's the end of the line.
We want Donald Trump to believe that 2020
is in the bag.
Every left wing voter needs to not believe
that the election is in the bag and that your
vote could make the difference in whatever
state you're voting in.
I did a story earlier today between foreign
interference and gerrymandering and voter
suppression, we will only win this election
if we overcome all of that stuff.
We can control turnout and enough turnout
will override all of that other stuff, period.
But you've got to get out there and vote.
We want Trump to think he's winning.
We want Trump to stay home.
But in the end, every single voter needs to
believe because it could be the case that
their vote could make or break their state
for Trump or whoever the eventual democratic
nominee will be.
That's the way I, I voted Massachusetts and
I'm still going to be operating under that
assumption.